hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
my channel where today we are recording
another q a
for june if you would like to ask any
questions for
next month's video in july leave them in
the comments section
of this video also my channel is
sponsored by keeps which means we will
hear more from them in the middle of the
video instead of youtube just randomly
putting ads everywhere
so the questions you had this month
sci-fi saturday said what's something
you love about america that you hate
about australia or vice versa
i love the coffee in australia it's very
good
i also really like the australian
attitude
um one of the things that really hit me
when i first got to australia
uh from two weeks ago at the start of
quarantine was there was a police
officer and then the general
manager of this hotel basically from the
jump were like
[ __ ] tired it's been a long day uh
you guys are probably [ __ ] tired on
your flight
here's the information just i feel like
nobody's performative and i think
americans often find that kind of thing
really rude
or awkward or uncomfortable uh where
you know growing up in another country
to me i find it so calming
people not giving a [ __ ] about me is
very calming whereas in america they're
like how are you guys doing you're from
out of town no way where are you from
what do you need
this is my favorite dish i just prefer
everybody to be a bit more low-key
joe farlon asked have you pre-ordered
dining light too yet i did after
watching a reaction video to the
gameplay trailer
said this for years years and years and
years
don't pre-order video games get that for
some people it helps you pay it off in a
better way or it helps you budget i
totally respect that
but if you're in a position where that
is not necessary i don't understand why
we keep giving people money
before we have actually been able to see
the product we don't even know what
we're buying and we're giving them money
months in advance i'm very
anti-pre-order
don't do it nick obas what's your dream
house i like a lot of light
and sun so something with big windows i
like being near the ocean
and generally i like really open not
cluttered spaces
couldn't be further from the tiny
apartment that i have which has no
balcony and
no like actual sun-facing windows but
one day we'll get there maybe probably
not the real estate market is
a [ __ ] disaster and it's it's ju this
whole generation is just screwed but
it's great it's great it's fine
jared asked any big plans for you to
still cover slash talk about a lot of
what's going on at e3 this year even
with you being busy with being back home
such family search work and all
yes so my plan for e3 is to cover
basically everything that i can
if i can do one of the live streams a
lot of this will depend on my parents
internet i will do one of those
youtube like event holder thingies um so
that you'll see that there's a
reminder for the live event and then i
will watch them live any that are during
my work hours because obviously work
comes first
i will record at a later date i'll do
every one live that i can
assuming i have good enough internet
connection or otherwise we'll catch up
that night or the next day or whenever i
have a free
free time no spimi9 said in all parts of
the games industry that you feel
confident commenting on gaming
journalism game development etc
how much is its who you know a thing i
would say
it is uh the exact same degree as
probably any other entertainment
industry
where it is you know a lot of creative
people in very large groups
collaborating to make something
extremely expensive um
yes knowing people helps however
in my experience at every company that
i've worked at every single one where
i've been in part of
a hiring process which is santa monica
studio
fun house rooster teeth and at ign
someone knowing someone and being able
to recommend them because it's not about
being friends it's about making sure
that you're like oh this person would be
good to work with oh i know this person
is good at this i have worked with this
person on this i know this person is a
good writer i know this person is
reliable i know this person
brings something valuable to the team
because i know that that can generally
get someone an interview
but it will not get someone a job so
even if you get the interview based on
recommendation which
is probably very common you still have
to go through like
interviews with 20 people spanning
generally several days
and every single person has to like you
especially if you're working on things
that
are really expensive which is a lot of
fast the games industry obviously
entertainment industry as well
where one person who doesn't fit the
team who someone on the team doesn't
like
who doesn't seem like they will bring
everything needed could really hurt a
project then they're not going to get
the job no matter who they're friends
with on the team
so i would say yeah who you know will
help you get an interview but it will
not help you
get an actual job there's just no way
there's too many people on too many
teams who need
to feel like you can do the job to make
sure the whole company doesn't burn down
because you're so important at these
companies that there is no
room for just like we'll just hire this
guy whatever i will say though
in the short film that i made and also
my awards show that i made being the
video game accessibility awards
for both of those i did solely hire
people i knew the award show was a
producer a host
an editor and a graphic designer and all
of them were people that i knew
and the reason i hired them was not
because i was like i'm gonna give my
mate a job
it's because they were people that i
knew could do the job that i needed them
to do i was positive
that they could do that job and i needed
that especially when i fully self-funded
the show
same as the the short film so i'm not
taking any risks basically
it's also that it's more fun to work
with friends on projects like that so
that's part of it too
i don't know that would span my whole
career like if i were a director at a
game studio i would not do that
because you need the top talent
especially in aaa development you need
someone to be [ __ ] perfect so that
[ __ ] doesn't fall apart you need to know
that they are super experienced and
someone that you know personally might
not fit that bill
jamie anson asked how do you feel about
western video games making female
characters less and less
sexy over time i don't necessarily feel
like this has happened
but truthfully i feel like there has
been a rise in
asking for realism of consumers
enjoying realism and that's maybe the
shift we're seeing is
as graphics get better it is easier to
make a more realistic looking woman
where previously
uh proportions had to be more extreme to
try to express something that appeared
to be feminine
with less pixels i am a person who has
always been very pro
uh women being sexy in games i am
totally fine with sexualized female
characters i am totally fine
with sexualized male characters i'm fine
with a female character being half naked
people are allowed to be hot
and characters are allowed to be hot or
allowed to be sexually attracted to
things
so on the same token because i don't
care about that i'm also completely fine
with women not being socialized in games
with women not being attractive in games
with not every women needing to be
attractive in games i generally am for
whatever you want to do
the only time it's ever bothered me is
when female characters personalities
are entirely intended to be sexy whether
dialogue is entirely
just sexual innuendo and they just hit
on the main character constantly
it happens really frequently with
villains with female villains and that's
something that my whole life i've been
like shut up
you're not a real character i wish you
were more interesting and that you were
less one-dimensional
and not just read dialogue that's saying
we would like you to be sexually
attracted this character
but yeah not something i never tried to
change that i have tried to change i had
any input on
but generally yeah my stance is i don't
know too much about this but if i were
to guess it would be
because of a recent strive for realism
in both environments and in character
design
that i feel like kind of have to move in
the same direction at the same time or
it's strange if they don't but if it
means that you wrote a [ __ ] character
who's really one dimensional and
uninteresting i am going to roll my eyes
and then just
go about my day not make a reddit thread
or tweet about it
and ignore the thing that i personally
dislike it's okay
it's time to talk about keeps
did you know that two out of three guys
will experience some form of male
pattern boldness by the time they're 35
the best way to prevent hair loss is to
do something about it while you still
have hair left
of course that's if you want to you're
beautiful anyway but i also love there
being options for men
who might feel insecure about this kind
of thing and keeps does work to make it
really comfortable with keeps a licensed
doctor will review your information
online and recommend the right hair loss
treatment plan for
you then your treatment is shipped
directly to your door
every three months you also have the
option to message your keeps doctor 24 7
with any questions or concerns you may
have along the way
and track your progress with keepsa's
progress tracking
tool so they really do get rid of any
awkward doctor visits and make
everything as comfortable and as
informative for you
as possible keeps also offers generic
versions of the fda approved medications
for hair loss which makes it more
affordable keeps treatments typically
take between four to six months to start
seeing results so it's important to act
fast and the sooner you start using
keeps the more hair you can save
find out why keebs has more five star
reviews than any of its competitors and
why hundreds of thousands of men trust
keeps for their hair loss prevention
if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to keeps.com
alana pierce or click the link in the
description to receive 50 off your first
order
that is k-e-e-p-s dot com slash alana
pierce
and back to the video big pumpy
nice sad so i guess the question i have
for you is how do you feel about
difficulty in video games i know you
like to involve yourself in a lot of
abled gaming stuff accessibility for the
most people that being said do you think
there's an argument to be made for
difficulty being a part of the art of a
game
great question the two things are not
mutually exclusive i feel like people
misunderstand this a lot
i think difficult games are awesome i
love a challenge i think that
studios should continue to make really
challenging difficult games
if that is what they want to do 100
do it that's super cool i like that
being a niche for that
even if it's not that niche frankly they
are really popular games the
accessibility part of that
is not asking for games to be easy
it's just asking for people with
disabilities to be able to play them
what that means is that people with
disabilities would also like to be able
to play
really hard games so they're not asking
for you to make the games easy
they are asking you to make it possible
for them to play hard games too
because they also want to play hard
games so that's the point that i feel
like people miss people aren't asking
for easy games they're asking to be able
to play hard games
just as hard as they intended for a very
good example for that uh is part of you
know what got me involved in caring
about accessibility
is i have tendinitis in both of my
wrists and i can't play anything that's
really button mashy
i had trouble with battle toads which
does not have good accessibility options
that game is real mashy and i had to ice
my wrists after playing it
and i recently saw that the new um
uh installment of the dark pictures
anthology
has an easy difficulty setting and what
that difficulty setting does
is reduce button mashing um
which you could say well that's an easy
mode it's ruining the difficulty of the
game what it's actually doing
is not removing the difficulty of the
game it's making it so that i can play
that game now without
pain oh cool j9 said what's a common
feature
aaa games continue to use that they that
you wish they'd drop
mine's very specific to being a writer
and this is a pet peeve
and it's not necessarily a feature it's
just an occurrence
something that drives me nuts is when
writing is used to excuse gameplay
so for example if something in a game is
repetitive
the gameplay is repetitive and then they
make the lead character say
ugh this again it's basically a trick
to make sure that players feel validated
if they're annoyed
and so they're like oh the character
acknowledged it though but he but they
said it which means they knew it was
repetitive
they knew so it's fine then and i'm like
no it's just a writing trick
it's still repetitive gameplay you can't
just write that away
even if it does seem like it works on a
lot of gamers they're like but it said
that
in the dialogue like they said that
after the fact
not before the fact to excuse
the gameplay issue so that's definitely
something i wish would go away
it's in a lot of games they do it all
the time carson jenkins said question do
you know what's going on with these
articles from game sites telling people
not to get a ps5
and it is very weird they tend to pop up
right before a major ps announcement
will stay to play is there some bad
blood between playstation folks
and folks in the industry um i don't
know what articles you're referring to i
think i've seen some tweets where people
are like i use my xbox more than my
playstation
uh i don't think it's weird at all that
they pop up before a major playstation
announcement or a state of play i think
that would make perfect sense that it's
just a human having playstation on their
brain and then being like this thing
made me think of playstation so now i'm
going to talk about playstation there's
no conspiracy it's just those people's
opinions
there's no there's no grand scheme
graham picture people paid off by xbox
thing that is
absolutely [ __ ] ridiculous seeing
some of that suggestion because some
people at ign have been saying that they
use their xbox series x more than their
playstation and people like this is paid
off
god oh every time i'm like you have no
idea how this works
if you don't disclose when you are paid
to say something which for the record
it is illegal to pay someone to say
something they don't believe so in any
sponsorship that i've ever done
it it is it's in their legal wording
you cannot say every single one of them
you cannot say something you don't
believe
you can say here are the talking points
for this product here's what they want
me to say
but if you say i feel this way and you
don't feel this weed that is illegal
they are not allowed to tell you to say
something you don't believe or you don't
do it is super illegal
but in any case like with this
conspiracy i've seen of people being
like oh
these ign employees were all paid off to
say they like xbox
um without disclosing an ad
the [ __ ] lawsuit that that would rain
down on microsoft
uh there's no conspiracy it's just
people just humans being
humans sharing opinions zack strockman
said not shaming or anything
but more genuinely curious but given
your job and the way the industry works
i notice you get a lot of
stuff for free not as much as people
think uh
are there ever times when you feel
awkward for getting a collector setter
of a particular game a pc component etc
for free when a typical consumer without
their own platform would have to pay
several hundreds of dollars for the same
um look there are caveats to this
i have once before raised a question of
hey if i'm getting this
why is it not available to the public
and the answer is like we have marketing
allocation these are never able to be
sold it's like this whole
insider business thing where me getting
one does not really
pertain to them being sold but um
generally the answer is
no i don't feel weird about it because
uh i've created something that is
valuable
so i understand why from a business
perspective
these companies see value in using the
thing that took me
10 years 11 years almost now to create
yeah i think because of the insane hard
work that i've put in
that even got me to the point that i'm
at especially considering the amount of
opportunities to quit i don't feel weird
about
recognizing the value of of what i've
created essentially
i do think there are some creators who
can be really entitled and i follow a
couple of pr people on twitter who talk
about this stuff
um like for example i will only ever
accept a game for free if i can get the
game early
and the only reason that i will even
take that is so that i can plan it
around my content schedule so if i can
get a game early
because i still work full-time of course
i have other priorities and commitments
that means that i'm more likely to be
able to schedule content around playing
it because i have a few days of heads up
i can do it on the weekend or something
um if the game comes out
and i have not been able to get a code
early i'll just buy the game he'll
always be like don't even send me a code
if i can't get it early i'll just buy it
i have no need to get
a free code i'd prefer not too frankly
unless i can get it early
well yeah i've seen pr people on twitter
post like screenshots of some of the
emails that they get from content
creators who are like
hey why won't you give me a free [ __ ]
code content goes so hard it is
disgusting that you're not
giving me this benefit where my approach
is like hey if there's any chance i
could get this early that would be super
helpful so that i can make content for
people on the internet so i can plan it
around my insanely busy schedule but if
not it's cool i'll just buy it thank you
bye
so there are limits to that when people
are [ __ ] but generally no if i get
something for free
it's because i've created an asset that
is very very valuable
to a company that's that's all it is you
are welcome to start your own business
and work for
11 straight years
you